NICOLE: Hello.
Welcome, everyone.
I am very delighted today
to introduce to you someone
whose work I greatly admire.
She is a very warm and
genuine person, and one
who speaks from the heart with
great authenticity, depth,
and candidness-- Ruth Ross,
the author of, "Coming
Alive, the Journey to Reengage
Your Life and Career."
My name is Nicole
[? Print, ?] and
I am a member of Google's
People Operations Team.
I myself am deeply fascinated
by the topic of engagement.
And when Ruth's book was brought
to the attention of our Google
Talks group, I was thrilled
to have the opportunity
to invite Ruth to speak here,
and was even more thrilled
when she accepted.
So Ruth has a history of 30
years as a human resources
executive at several world
renowned brands such as Wells
Fargo, American Express,
and Charles Schwab.
And today, she will tell us a
bit about her own experience
with disengagement throughout
her talking through her book.
RUTH K. ROSS: Great.
NICOLE: So if you please join
me in welcoming Ruth Ross.
RUTH K. ROSS: Great, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank You.
NICOLE: Having admitted to
being disengaged at one point
yourself, can you give us a
little bit of your back story
in terms of your
experience and why
you decided to write this book?
RUTH K. ROSS: Sure.
First of all, thank
you so much for coming.
I know there are many choices
you have to do with your time,
especially at lunch.
And so I'm very honored
that you're here.
And so let me just
start off by giving you
a little bit of a
quick background.
As Nicole said, I was a
human resources executive
for 30 years.
So that means I started
when I was a teenager.
And we're all just going
to believe that premise,
and go from there.
And so I worked the
first half of my career
in New York City for
some incredible companies
and spent time down
on Wall Street.
And in 1996, was recruited
by Charles Schwab
to come to San Francisco.
Best decision I ever made.
First of all, come on.
Let's be real.
Living in the Bay Area, but
worked for a phenomenal company
at a time when they were
growing substantially.
And then spent the last
10 years of my career
as an executive VP of
HR for Wells Fargo Bank
during some of the
most turbulent times
that one could ever imagine
in the workplace, right?
2008, the world's
coming to an end
from a financial perspective.
And I was actually
working for the CFO
of the company at the time.
And not long after, Wells
Fargo did a major acquisition,
doubled in size overnight.
And you can just
imagine the kind
of craziness and the
amount of work that ensued.
And somewhere along the way, I
want to say kind of late 2010,
I had what I referred to as my,
"face in the mirror," moment.
So like we all do, we get up in
the morning and take a shower,
get dressed.
And I was looking in the
mirror, combing my hair,
putting on my makeup.
Thankfully, my husband was
already out of the house.
And I literally stopped,
looked in the mirror,
and I just screamed
out loud-- and I'll
make it clean because
we're on video,
but-- when are you
ever going to admit
that you are
completely dead inside?
Just screamed it.
Kind of stood there and said,
my passion for what I did
was gone.
I had always prided myself
that I was very passionate.
I believed in what I did.
But I was dead inside.
And there are just
so many reasons.
And we'll talk more about
that as we get into this.
But that was my epiphany, my
"face in the mirror" moment.
And I knew, in that split
second that I screamed,
that I had to do something
about it to change my life.
Fast forward, kind
of created a plan.
Circumstances arose
such that I was
able, about nine
months later, to be
able to walk away and
start my new life.
And my new life
was all about doing
what I was passionate
about and what gave me joy.
And part of that
was helping others.
And I won't make anyone
raise their hands,
because I would never
embarrass people this way.
But if you just
think to yourself,
my guess is, every one of us
has either been through this
personally, know
someone close to us--
a friend, a colleague,
a relative--
who's gone through some
bout with disengagement.
Or maybe you manage
someone who's disengaged,
because I bet
everyone of us has.
It's that pervasive out there.
70% of the US workforce
has identified
themselves as disengaged.
That means only 30% are truly
engaged in what they do.
And my guess is they're all
sitting right here in Google
and not anywhere else.
And in the world, only
13% of people are engaged.
So it's a pretty big issue.
And I started talking to people
about what I went through.
And everybody had a story.
And the next thing you know,
I did something really crazy.
I decided to write a book.
And I'm sitting here today.
NICOLE: Why did you decide to
call the book, "Coming Alive,
The Journey to Reengage
Your Life and Career?"
RUTH K. ROSS: So
the reason I decided
to call the book what I did
is that a couple of things
happened for me along the way.
The first is that,
when we go to school
and we decide upon our career,
we embark on our first job,
nobody hands you a
roadmap-- are there
still roadmaps out there--
or a GPS device, right?
Nobody hands that to you.
It's, go forth.
Go work.
And you don't think
about a career
that you're passionate
about, it's about a job.
And really what it
is, it's a journey.
And over the course
of your working life,
you may start out at
one place, but you're
going to go through a lot
of detours along the way.
And that's what
engagement's really about.
It's that journey to
start an engagement
to get to where you want to be.
You may detour
into disengagement,
and hopefully end up
back at reengagement.
The second reason I
called it what I did
is because I started to
realize that this isn't just
about a work issue.
You can't compartmentalize
your life.
What happens at work
affects you at home.
And what happens at home
impacts you at work.
If you're dealing with
some issues at home--
whether it's maybe with
children, or financial issues,
or relationship issues-- and
you're stressed out about that,
trust me, when you get dressed
in the morning, that stress
gets dressed with you
and comes into work.
If you're dealing with an
issue in the workplace--
let's say you are
being bullied at work.
I've been through that.
I don't just leave
that at the door
when I leave the
office at night.
Those feelings
come home with you.
And so that's why I decided
to really look at this as
about being reengaged
and coming alive in both
your work and your life.
NICOLE: Throughout your
book, and as you mentioned,
you highlight that
disengagement affects everyone
from college students
to executives.
And your book is written in
a very practical and personal
manner, rather than
as an academic study.
Was this your intent to
write the book that way?
And if so, why did you choose
to write in that style?
RUTH K. ROSS:
Absolutely my intent.
It was not accidental.
You know, engagement is
a topic that, believe me,
there are thousands of books
out there on this topic.
Everyone is talking about it.
And there's some incredible
works that are out there.
And there's a lot of
people who have written
from a very academic and
theoretical perspective.
And that's great.
And I admire many of them.
That's not me.
I'm really of the plain talking,
from the heart, keep it simple
and tell stories, because
this really is personal.
And I wanted something that
is really easy to read,
that you can pick up at
any time and get through it
in one sitting.
It's only 126 pages.
And I think the best
compliment that I've
heard from people who have read
the book is when I hear people
say things to me like, it was
the first time since college
that I took out a highlighter.
And I dog-eared some pages.
And I just keep
going back to it.
I can't have a better
compliment than that.
So truly, that's
exactly what I wanted.
NICOLE: Now, in
your book, you say
that engagement can occur
at an exquisite level
between your heart,
and soul, and career.
What's the connection
for you between your work
on reengagement and your heart?
RUTH K. ROSS: There
is such a connection.
You know, we all think about
the heart and how-- you know,
I'm looking around this
room, and a lot of you
are trying to eat
really healthy today.
Not all of you,
but a lot of you.
And it's all about exercising.
We were talking
earlier about running.
And there's so much that
people do to really work
on being heart healthy,
when, truth be told,
you also have to work on
it from a work perspective.
When you love what
you do and you're
passionate about what you
do, it impacts your heart
in a really great way.
And you know, one
of the things I
think about, when we hear
the word, engagement--
and if you're not
someone like Nicole
and I who live about this
stuff and we study it--
but to most people, engagement
is when you commit yourself
in a deeply committed
partnership with the person you
love.
It's when one person usually
gets down on one knee
and asks someone to marry
them or be in a partnership.
But truth be told,
you can also really
commit in a deep way to
the mission and vision
and values of a
company, as well.
And when I think about this,
and I think about some examples,
when people just say, I do
a job, as versus a career,
think about the doctor
who doesn't just
say they practice
medicine, but rather they
tell you they save lives.
Or a personal injury attorney
who doesn't just practice law,
but they actually stand
up for others who can't.
Or maybe it's the
owner of a mom and pop
pharmacy who stays an hour
after closing because he heard
that a little boy in the
neighborhood was sick
and needed medicine.
Or it's the chef who owns
an Italian restaurant
and gets up at the crack of
dawn to make pasta from scratch,
because that's how
his grandmother did it
in the old country.
That's not about just
going to a job, that's
being passionate about
the work that you do.
And I'll share a quick,
little story with you
that really brings
it home for me
around the question that
Nicole just asked me.
So my mother-in-law
is 89 years old.
And she's had Alzheimer's
for a number of years now.
And she's doing fantastic.
She's really,
really doing great.
And my husband is very
diligent about calling her
on a frequent basis.
And when you have a
conversation with someone
who has Alzheimer's, some day,
it can be a great conversation.
And some days, you struggle.
Right?
It's difficult.
Well, on this particular
day, she was doing fantastic.
And she was asking about me.
And my husband, whose name
is Sandy, said to her, Mom,
do you remember?
I told you Ruth
was writing a book.
Well, I'm really excited to
tell you, she's now finished it.
And it's with the publisher.
And so she asked my
husband, what's it about?
And he said, with
some trepidation,
he said, it's about
employee engagement.
And the reason he hesitated
was, his mother has not
been in the workplace in
probably over 50, 55 years.
How is she going to understand
what employee engagement is?
So he takes a deep
breath, and he
gets ready to tell her what
employee engagement is all
about.
And she stops him mid-sentence
and said, oh, honey, I
know what that's about.
That's when you
have employees who
are hands-on and have
their hearts open.
Can't say it better than that.
NICOLE: Very cool.
So at Google, we strive to
create a magical culture
and magical experiences
for our employees.
What are the must-haves
a company needs in order
to achieve high engagement?
RUTH K. ROSS: Yeah,
it's a great question
because, when I did ask around a
little bit about Google, what's
the one word you'd use
to describe culture,
and I did hear quite
a bit about magic.
And for me, there is a magic
when you hit high engagement.
And there are really
five must-haves
that employees want
from their employers.
And the first is meaning.
People want to work for a
company that has meaning.
You can't get much
better than this company.
The things that
you do and create
here change people's lives.
That's meaning.
You know, another company
I love to highlight
is Tom's Shoes, down
in Southern California.
For every pair of shoes you buy,
Tom donates a pair of shoes.
For every bag of coffee
you buy, they donate water
to people in need.
That is incredible meaning.
The next must-have is alignment.
And alignment is
all about, every day
when you come into
work, you want
to know exactly where
the company is going.
What's the mission?
What's the purpose?
What are you doing?
Why are you here?
It's about being transparent.
So alignment is really important
no matter where you work.
The third must-have is growth.
So back when I was
working in the workplace,
we actually had things like
career ladders, you know?
You start at one
level, and then you
move to the next level
and the next title.
Thankfully, that is long gone.
And now, it's all about growth.
It's about learning new things,
working on different projects.
There are so many
programs here at Google
where you can transition
from one project to another,
or bungee in and do
something, and then go back
to what you were doing.
That's all about creating
an artist pallet of skills,
as versus, how am I
getting to the next level
and the next level?
The fourth must-have is input.
Every one of you
in this room today
and all of your colleagues
are here at Google
because you know
that people want
to hear what you have to say.
And they ask you for
your opinion-- I hope--
and you give input
to what's going on.
There's nothing worse than
working in an environment where
that feels stifled,
and you don't
feel like you have a voice.
And the final-- and by now,
hopefully, you've figured out
I'm probably going to spell
magic-- so the fifth is, C,
is context.
And context is all about
the simple question of why.
When you ask a kid
to do something,
the first thing they
say to you is, why?
That doesn't change when
you get into the workplace.
People want to understand
the why behind the what.
And if you do nothing
else to create magic,
it's about that context.
Don't just make decisions
and tell people, but really
explain what's
behind the decision.
Because I promise you,
if leaders do that,
people will follow them.
And that will create magic.
NICOLE: Throughout the
book, a lot of your stories
are representative of people
in very different stages
throughout their careers.
How would you address
the misconception
that disengagement only occurs
after someone's been in a role
for a really long time and
have been somewhat jaded?
RUTH K. ROSS: There's definitely
a misconception about that.
People think the longer
you've been in the job,
the more that this happens.
Truth be told, disengagement
doesn't discriminate.
It doesn't matter if
you are first year out,
if you're 30 years
into a career.
It doesn't matter if you're
a secretary, or you're a CEO.
It doesn't matter what part
of the country or the world
you live in.
It can happen to
anyone at any time.
I'm even seeing this
on college campuses
where people are
saying to me, wow,
I need to take a step back,
because I'm in a major
that, maybe, this isn't
really what I want to do.
So this happens to
people at all levels.
And I'll tell you a quick,
funny story to illustrate this.
About a year, year
and a half ago,
I had a client I work with
out in Salt Lake City.
And so I travel from the
Bay Area to Salt Lake a lot.
And when you fly out, it's
these little two and two
across planes, so kind of
those intimate sardine cans.
And I'm sitting on the aisle.
And I met my neighbor, who
was in the window seat, when
he went to put his bag in
the overhead compartment,
and his computer fell
and hit me in the head.
Not a way I'd recommend
of meeting your seat mate.
And of course, he
was very apologetic.
And we started to
chat when he sat down.
And we were talking
about what he does.
And he creates videos in
the advertising space.
And he asked me what I did.
And I explained that
I was writing a book
about reengaging in
life and disengagement.
And he turned to me and he
said, here's my contact info.
I'm going through that now.
You should interview
me for the book.
So I said, great.
Took his card.
And he went back to do his work.
And I went to read, probably,
some embarrassing magazine
like "US" or "People."
And about two minutes later, I
get a tap on my right shoulder
from the woman across the aisle.
And by the way, this guy
was probably in his 30s,
I would say.
I get a tap from this woman.
And she whispers to me, I
didn't mean to listen in,
but I'd love to
talk to you as well.
I've gone through that.
And as a matter of fact, I'm
now relocating to the Bay Area
to take a new job
with my company
to hopefully get reengaged.
And I said, who do you work for?
She goes, shh.
And she points to her lapel
where there's a little pin.
And it was the pin from the
airline that we were flying on.
I said, OK.
Shh.
So I take her information.
And about 20 minutes
later, we land.
And I'd say that she was
probably in her 40s, early 40s.
And on these small planes, you
have to gate check your bag.
So I'm waiting at the jet way to
get my bag to go to my meeting,
and a woman comes up,
stands next to me.
And probably a woman
in her early 60s.
And she turns to me and
says, I was eavesdropping.
I was sitting in the
aisle behind you,
and I'd love to
talk to you as well.
It turned out, she lived a block
away from me in San Francisco.
There you have it,
three generations.
NICOLE: How and when does
disengagement happen?
And what are some of
the underlying causes
that lead to disengagement?
RUTH K. ROSS: So disengagement
can happen in a moment
where you least expect it.
And you can slide
in and out of this.
And the best analogy
I can give is
that many of us, when
we were children,
had a seesaw in a playground
or in our backyard
that we played on.
And if you think about
a seesaw, the intent
is to be level and remain level.
But any little motion
can cause one person
to soar high, and another
one to crash your butt
right on the floor.
And a seesaw's in
constant motion.
And that's what happens with
engagement and disengagement.
You kind of float from
one thing to another.
It's not usually one
particular event,
but I call it a
series of paper cuts.
My boss yelled at me in front
of some colleagues today-- paper
cut.
My project got rejected
by someone-- paper cut.
They just announced the third
reorganization in a year,
and this one's dumber than
the previous two-- paper cut.
Right?
So each one in itself,
you just deal with,
just like a paper cut.
Oh, it's annoying.
And you complain.
And then you go
about your business.
But when one starts to
happen on top of another,
on top of another, it
starts to cut deeper,
and you start to bleed.
And that's kind of what happens.
And so I mentioned
earlier that there
are lots of people
who have written books
around engagement.
And the one thing we have
in common is that many of us
agree on some of the
underlying causes that
tend to bring this
feeling about.
The first is the job's
not what was promised.
Right?
How many of us have been
sold something really great
about a job?
And then we get there,
and we get involved in it,
and we're sort of like, what?
And you begin to feel like the
square peg in the round hole.
That's one way.
Another is this
feeling of being stuck.
Maybe you've been in
the job for a long time.
You're not moving
to the next level,
or learning the new skill,
or maybe your compensation's
been frozen because you're
at the max of that level.
That's feeling stuck.
A third way is lack of
appreciation or recognition.
How simple is it just to say,
thank you for a job well done?
And I know you've got
lots of initiatives
here to appreciate
and recognize people.
But sometimes, just a simple
thank you from a manager
can go a long way.
The fourth underlying
cause is a bad manager.
And these are usually people
who have every great intention
in the world, but they
don't know how to manage.
And think about a
company like this,
where you have a lot
of amazing people
that are individual
contributors.
And you might be the best
technology person in the world,
or the best marketing
person, or whatever.
But somebody taps you on the
shoulder and goes, hey, Nicole.
Congratulations,
you're now a manager.
First thing I say is, now what?
That doesn't mean that you get
up all of a sudden the next day
and go, oh, I know
how to manage.
I know how to coach and
write performance reviews
and do all of that stuff.
And so that's the bad
manager, well-intentioned,
but needs some help.
And the fifth is one
that's most troubling,
because it's epidemic right now.
And that's bullying or a
toxic work environment.
And again, I won't
embarrass anyone by saying,
have you ever
worked for a bully?
But trust me, many of us have.
Those bullies are everywhere
in the corporate environment.
And that kind of toxicity
is one the leading causes
of disengagement.
NICOLE: Through these
causes, are there
symptoms that someone would
show when they're disengaged?
And how can we be better at
recognizing and diagnosing
those symptoms?
RUTH K. ROSS: So I think
what happens with symptoms
is that, first, you
want to think about
what does a great, engaged,
magical culture look like?
Right?
And we can look around
Google and see a lot of that.
But not every
company is as lucky.
But the holy grail
is companies where
you see people who are really
creative, and innovative,
and willing to take risks.
And they're energetic
about what they do.
And they're committed.
And you feel that vibrancy.
What happens with disengagement
is it shows up in two ways.
It shows up individually, and
it shows up organizationally.
So let's talk
individually first.
From an individual
perspective, what
you start to see in
people, maybe you
start to notice some mood
swings that, maybe, you
hadn't seen before.
All of a sudden, people start
coming in a little later,
maybe leaving a little earlier.
Maybe they're absent
a little bit more.
In meetings, they
isolate themselves.
You know, kind of like
they sit back with the arms
folded, don't contribute like
they used to, maybe slipping
on deadlines.
They give poor customer service.
And you can see this
kind of lethargy, right?
The energy just really
kind of slows down.
And then organizationally--
organizations
that have low
engagement overall tend
not to be creative
and innovative.
They're not comfortable
with change.
They don't have great customer
service and relationships.
And depending on
the industry, they
might have increased
safety issues,
because people aren't
really paying attention.
So it can manifest
itself in different ways.
NICOLE: In the book, you
refer to the treatment
to this as your
alive treatment plan.
What is your secret to
effective reengagement?
RUTH K. ROSS: So thank
you, for asking that.
So on the screen,
when we had it up,
where you saw "alive" in
the title of the book,
I did that for a reason.
As I've talked about
some of this stuff,
there's underlying causes,
and there's symptoms,
and you can diagnose it, it
sounds kind of medical, right?
People in poor health.
And so I really wanted
to come up with something
to get people back
to good health.
And I call that, "alive."
And here's really
the key to this.
It's just a conversation
like we're having today.
It's about connecting.
I think people have
lost the art of how
to connect with each other.
I had a boss that never
had one-on-one meetings.
And everything was
done through email.
There was no connecting.
And so it really has its
roots in, what I call,
a "stay conversation."
It's holistic medicine.
You can do it at any time.
It's not about performance.
So what I advocate is a
five-step where I say,
a manager and employee
should have a conversation
about twice a year where this
is not about performance.
Go out and have a cup of coffee,
or come to 1 of 23 cafeterias
here.
Just sit down.
Get out of the office.
Just have a conversation
and connect.
And so the A in
alive is about ask.
And the ask is just having
a conversation about,
how are things going?
What's really working for you?
What's not?
What obstacles are in your way?
What stops you from being
excited about getting up
in the morning and
coming into work?
Or conversely, what makes
you want to jump out of bed
and come to work?
And the next step is, listen.
And the listen is about
listen to what people say,
but also what they don't say.
The body language is
equally as important.
So if I'm having a conversation
with Nicole, who's my manager.
And she's asking me something.
And I'm sitting there,
and I'm not really
looking at you in the eye, and
I'm looking down at the ground.
She might want to think,
there's something going on here.
There's something
that's a pain point.
But conversely, if I'm
talking about something,
like a new initiative,
and I'm excited,
and my eyes light up like
bulbs on a Christmas tree,
you want to note that
as well, because that
might be something to work on.
The next step is,
I, for identify.
And that's really when it's
about the manager saying,
I'm going to think about
this the next 24 hours.
What did I hear from Ruth?
What did I see?
And now, I want to come
up with one to two, maybe
three reaction steps.
I want to react to
what I heard and saw
to come up with some ideas
to reengage that person.
And then the V is
validation where
the manager and the
person get back together
within the same week
for a short meeting
just to say, hey,
great meeting with you.
Heard what you had to say.
Great conversation.
I have some ideas I
want to run by you.
You looked really
excited when you
talked about bringing in this
author to come speak at Google.
I'd love you to take charge
of that and invite them in.
Or I'd love you to
work on this project.
Or I could tell that how many
steps it takes in the sales
process to close
a sale is painful.
I think we can work on
ways to skinny that down.
Right?
That's validating
the conversation.
And E is simply
executing on the plan.
It's that simple.
And it really works.
And it doesn't
cost you anything.
And especially here, because
the coffee's free, right?
So there's no cost.
Why not do it?
NICOLE: If you identify
that you are disengaged
and you decide to
stay, what is your call
to action for people
with regard to this book?
And what can they do if
they are in this spot
or see someone else?
RUTH K. ROSS: I think
what's really important
to understand is this
is not rocket science.
I will leave the rocket
science to you guys.
This is not at all.
This is so incredibly simplistic
that, sometimes, even I
shake my head and say,
is it really this simple?
And the answer is, yes.
And so there's a
couple of things--
and I talked in the question
before about a manager having
a conversation.
If your manager's not offering
to have that conversation,
ask for it.
Invite them.
Right?
And the whole point of
this is you have a choice.
Anyone has a choice.
If you have friends who are
going through this that maybe
work for a company that's
not as magical as Google,
tell them to find their voice.
Because really, there's only
three things that happen.
When I had my moment-- if they
have their "face in the mirror"
moment, and they reflect,
and they say, I'm disengaged,
they can choose to
just say, I own it.
That's what's happening.
And I need to be here.
And I'm going to be here
until something changes,
until maybe I get
to a place where
I can do something different.
But I own that choice.
Or you could choose to go
to your manager and say,
I'd love to tweak some things.
Think about the things
you guys have here
where you can go
do some other work.
You can do explorations.
You can do bungee.
You can spend up to 20%, I
think it is of your time,
working on other projects.
That's the single best cure
for disengagement around.
I wish other companies would
learn from what you guys do,
because that's
incredibly powerful.
What that's saying
is, we don't want
to lose the employees
who are here.
We value them.
You are the
competitive advantage.
Why wouldn't you have
that kind of conversation
and be free to have that?
Or frankly, the third choice
is you can just choose to say,
you know what?
I'm going to go
do something else.
I'm going to walk away.
And it may not happen overnight.
And it's about creating
lifelines, and creating a plan,
and think about what you do.
And one of the things I
tell people, particularly
people that are earlier
on in their career,
and I would say to
every one of you,
everyone tells you to
save for retirement.
And you absolutely, 1,000%, need
to be saving for retirement.
But you also need to save
for a walk-away fund,
so that you have the
ability to not feel stuck,
if that's how you feel, but
that you have the ability
to do something else and to
be able to say, you know what?
Not right for me now.
I'm going to walk away.
And the thing that
I tell people is,
you always want to
walk towards something,
instead of running
away from something
that's maybe not as good.
Because the power's all
within you to find your voice.
And to bring this
all back full circle,
that's what happened to me.
I had those feelings
that it wasn't right.
And truthfully, I
felt invisible, even
in a very visible role.
And I had to create a lifeline
so that I could take control
and say, I'm never going to
let that happen to me again.
I need to go do something
I'm passionate about.
And that's when the best
work comes in, no matter
whether it's here, or another
company, or in my case,
in my own home office.
So at that, just
looking at the time,
why don't we stop there and
see if there are questions?
NICOLE: Yes.
Yes.
Definitely, like to open
it up any questions.
RUTH K. ROSS: The
question is about,
with technology being what it
is and everybody just totally
connected and wired, is that
really having an impact?
And I would say, absolutely.
And it's always going
to be what it is,
but it takes us
away from connecting
and having conversations.
And truth be told, when I
talked about alive, if you have
that conversation
even once, maybe
twice a year with the person
you work for, it doesn't matter
that those other times you
might be working remotely
or connected in with
technology, because now you
have the basis of
that conversation that
can help shape things.
So I'm not saying you have
to put it aside all the time,
but somehow you've got to mix
it in with that connecting.
When I had a boss who only spoke
with me through technology,
why would I be
connected and engaged
and passionate about what
I was doing, when I never
had that face-to-face
interaction?
So you've got to just
find that balance.
And it's just a
small balance, but it
can make all the
difference in the world.
NICOLE: Yeah.
RUTH K. ROSS: So
the question is,
I had this moment
when I was yelling
at myself in the mirror,
and then I wrote a book.
And so what happened in between?
And it was a couple
year process.
So really, for me,
I knew something
wasn't right for a long time.
But you get so focused on the
work, and we were so busy,
and there was so
much going on that I
think I just tampered it down.
And so that day was,
finally, the paper cuts
had now bled so much that I just
said, oh, my god, something's
not right here.
And one of the
first things I did
was to really confide in
a couple of people close
to me to say, I feel this way.
And I think I have to
do something different.
One of the first
things I did, no joke,
as I thought about
my plan, was I went
and met with my banker to look
at my finances, to really,
truly understand where
I was in my life.
And with retirement
and financially,
could I think about doing
something different?
So I became very planful, very
thoughtful and very planful.
And I took a piece of paper out.
Plain white sheet of
paper-- forget technology,
you could do it on your iPhone.
But literally, I went
back to the basics.
And I drew a line
down the page, and I
said, make it or break it.
What do I need to have?
And what can I not
live with anymore?
And I knew I couldn't live
with a bully boss anymore.
I knew I couldn't live
with feeling invisible.
But I knew I wasn't ready to
just walk away and do nothing.
But I also knew that I could
walk away and get another HR
job.
I had a great background.
I had a great reputation.
I could have gotten another job.
But when I looked at that piece
of paper, no boss, no more.
I knew my make it or break it.
So I just started thinking about
it and started being planful.
And I knew it wasn't
going to happen overnight,
but I just started working
on getting right in my head
and talking to people
and having conversations.
And ultimately, some things
happened with reorganizations
and others where it was the
right time to walk away.
So then, fast forward.
OK, I'm now at home.
I've made the decision,
I'm not going back
to a company environment.
I have elderly
parent issues that I
was dealing with back East.
I was volunteering for great
nonprofit organizations.
I was doing all of that.
But I couldn't get
away from the fact
that there was a story
to tell inside of me.
And so I just kept saying,
OK, OK, what's next?
So I'd say, from the time I
left, it was about two years
before I sat down
to write the book.
So it doesn't just
happen overnight.
But I will tell you that
every day of those two years,
and the time that's
happened since, I get up
out of bed every day
loving my life right now
and being passionate
about what I do.
And I think that was the
real difference for me.
So I just had to be planful and
thoughtful and make it happen.
Sure.
So the question is that,
in the research that he's
done on this topic,
a lot of times,
you see things like
employee satisfaction.
I thought you were also going to
bring up "happy," because that
also comes up in this, right?
Oh, that's about being happy.
Truth be told, they're
all different things.
So employee engagement is really
about that connected loyalty
to what you do, and believing
in that, and the mission
and the purpose and
the meaning that you
find in a company like this.
That doesn't always mean
that you're happy every day.
Right?
And truth be told, some
people who are really
engaged in what they
do may not be happy,
because they see things that are
broken that they want to fix.
And companies used to
measure employee satisfaction
before they morphed
into engagement surveys.
And employee satisfaction is
this big overarching thing
that you're never quite
sure, what does that mean?
So I think, over time, you
can be engaged in what you do,
but not be satisfied,
because you
want to change the status quo.
And you want to be an innovator.
And you want to be a
disruptor who said,
I'm going to change the world.
So I may not be
satisfied yet, because I
want to get us to here.
So that's why I see
them as different.
Well, they're all important.
I just see them as different.
And engagement,
for me, is really
about the holy
grail of saying, I'm
just really committed to
what we're trying to do here.
And I think that's what
you want to reach for,
if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
RUTH K. ROSS: Right?
So not always about happy.
Great question.
Thank you, so much.
Yes?
So the question
is about bullying.
So in today's society, the
stories that make the news
are the kids that are being
bullied on the playground,
or the guy at Rutgers
University, Tyler Clementi,
years ago, who killed himself
when his roommate spied on him.
Or maybe you remember
the story about Karen,
the school bus driver, who
got bullied by the kids.
And people around the
world were so incensed,
they ended up
contributing over $800,000
to a women they
didn't even know.
Those are the stories that
are all over the media.
Or the kids in Florida,
12 and 14 years old,
that caused someone
to commit suicide.
Truth be told, the
largest percentage
of bullying in the world
today is in the workplace.
And I have a favorite slide.
Obviously, I'm not
using slides here.
But I pull it up, and it
says, bully, B-U-L-L-Y.
And it stands for
big, ugly, lonely,
losers yearning for attention.
Because there are a lot of
police in the workplace,
and they take shape of things
like the intimidater, who
thinks that by being the
loudest voice in the room,
if they yell the loudest, it'll
make them the most important.
Or the snake-in-the-grass,
who may just put you down
at the same time they're
taking credit for what you do.
Or the sexist bully, who may
say to someone-- usually a man
to a woman-- something that's
so derogatory to put them
in their place.
That stuff is out there
in a really big way.
I stopped counting
at four, but I've
had at least four bully
bosses in my career.
And it's demoralizing,
because it
zaps you of your
self-confidence.
And you just kind of
go, wait a minute.
What is this?
And you tend to think
you're a victim.
And that's the
worst possible thing
you could do because, truth
be told, you may be a target.
But trust me, you
are not a victim.
It's their problem, not yours.
Right?
But that's happening.
And organizations today
are really inept when
it comes to shutting
down bullies.
They don't know how to do it.
And I'll say this in a
really embarrassing way,
because I know I have people in
HR here that are in the room.
And I was one of
them for a long time.
Some of my worst
bullies were people
that managed HR functions.
And I'd say, but
they're the ones
who are supposed to
be changing the world.
So that's what's happening
in companies today,
that's so pervasive.
So it is absolutely one
of the biggest causes
of why people get
disengaged and shut down.
The question really is
about-- yes, managers
are supposed to lead and do
things right, but some of them
just don't know how to do that,
and aren't comfortable in that.
And there's a lot
of conflict around.
And so I'm going to
answer that in a way,
because there's some things
that I didn't get a chance
to talk about that I want
to bring out in this.
And the first one is,
every one of us is a CEO.
And I don't mean a
chief executive officer
because, frankly, who the
heck wants all that pressure?
But a CEO stands for
Chief Engagement Officer.
And we can all wear
those titles proudly
because, truth be told,
you can't just wait around
for somebody to create an
engaged environment for you,
or a satisfied environment,
with the previous question.
Every one of you have to own it.
As employees, you
need to own that
and own your own engagement.
And part of this really is
having a voice and speaking up,
but doing it in such a way
that it's not confrontational.
And there are many
ways of doing that.
And I sort of call
it an "I message,"
where it's a more quiet,
kind of reflective
of, I'd like to let you know
how I'm feeling about something,
and really trying to have that
conversation and take the lead,
because here's the
really sad part.
When you think about engagement
and disengagement out there,
a large percentage of people
who are disengaged today
are managers.
They're managers.
And so if you think
about it, a dead battery
can't charge another.
If you're not engaged, how are
you going to engage your team?
And it's about trying to get
that and have that happen.
And I've literally seen teams
that have said, you know what?
We're going to be
a self-managed team
and engage ourselves and do
those things because we own it.
We're CEOs.
And so it's just trying
all those different things.
And at the end of
the day, what's
so awesome about a company
like this is that, if it's not
working where you are, you have
unbelievable opportunities here
to do something else and
find that manager who
is going to be that engaging
kind of leader that you need.
NICOLE: Join me in thanking
Ruth for all of her insights
and for coming and
joining us today.
RUTH K. ROSS:
Thank you, so much.
[APPLAUSE]